for years Muhammad hejazi dug people out
of collapsed buildings after bombing
raids by the Syria armed forces and the
Russian allies on February 6 he woke up
to a different disaster
a powerful earthquake whose epicenter
was across the border in southern turkey
leveled neighborhoods across the
opposition-controlled northwest of Syria
he pulled bodies from rubble and saved
others but Muhammad tells us how a story
of Hope can quickly turn into tragedy
we saw a child's hair in the rubble we
wanted to reach her we use our hand to
remove the debris until we found her
with her mother who was holding her they
were both dead there's also a dead man
close to them then my colleague heard a
feigned voice under the bodies there was
a child crying she was saying I'm here
that voice was of nine-year-old Anwar
she was still alive more than 40 hours
since the initial earthquake civil
defense volunteers used their hands to
dig because they didn't have
sophisticated equipment to reach
survivors quickly when we heard the
voice we were overwhelmed with joy
especially since we're only removing
bodies I spoke to her for almost two
hours
Muhammad Ahmad was also hopeful that at
least one member of his family was still
alive
he wasn't in his village when the
earthquake struck
people in this corner of Syria no
tragedy all too well it's home to
Millions who are no strangers to death
destruction and displacement
when I arrived here on Tuesday night I
saw a building on the ground my whole
family was under the rubble until I
heard the faint voice of Anwar when I
heard her I had so much hope but that
changed when they told me she didn't
survive
Anwar was still breathing when Muhammad
removed her from the debris
all right
baby
they tried to save her life but the
nine-year-old didn't make it to hospital
I still remember how scared she was how
she cried I tried to keep her calm but
she kept holding my hand asked me not to
let the roof Crush her
Muhammad had to give her lifeless body
wrapped in a blanket to her father
since that day he says he can still feel
the touch of anwar's hand